[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome to
culture binge wisecracks culture podcast
where we talk about everything going on
in the zeitgeist i am michael and joined
today by a wisecrack writer alec hey and
wisecrack researcher sir b hi how is
everyone doing today
I'm pretty great I'm excited about
everything we have on deck today and we
even have a special guest coming up I'm
not gonna say who or what for just yet
because first I need to hear what has
been both slapping and champing in the
lives of my esteemed co-hosts since we
were last together two weeks ago so sir
B you want to go start it sure so so
many things chopped this past a couple
of weeks I learned about a human
trafficking trap that's going on in
target parking lots my target parking
lots yeah so this is what happens I'm
gonna do like a super abbreviated
version because it's like a PSA for
everybody especially women so what
happens is if you're walking in the
parking lot another woman will come up
to you and she will say like help me
help me and act super distressed you'll
start to follow her and what happens is
that she has her car parked into the
parking spot next to her there will be a
van that's parked outward so they backed
into the spot and what'll happen is she
will open her driver's side door so she
blocks that exit and then the guy in the
van will open his driver's side no block
that exit somebody will open the van
sliding door put you in drugged you and
then they'll take you off and human
traffic you this is a true story because
my manager had this happen to her she
didn't get taken out right she um I'm
smiling just because I'm deeply
uncomfortable and nervous about this
yeah that's why just so everyone knows
I'm not smiling very tactfully she got
to the point where she was almost in
between the two cars when she was like
when she saw them
in the car and man in the van and she
thought to herself why did this woman
run all the way across the parking lot
to ask me for help when there's a man
next to her so she stopped and she said
what do you need help with and the woman
was like uh mom I need help with um and
she couldn't come up with an answer
so then she turned around and like ran
into the store and she called the police
and the police came and said oh this is
a you know very common human trafficking
tactic and they would have they would
have put you in the van they would have
gone onto the freeway and taking you
down to Mexico so I heard this back in
August and I was like holy [ __ ] that's
crazy
then I was at Target my local Target
that is like ten minutes from my house
and I'm with my best friend from high
school and so we're talking and she's
like she's getting weirded out because
there's this woman in the parking lot
just like standing there and so as we're
walking back to her car she's like what
is that woman doing and I'm like I don't
know maybe she's waiting for a ride or
something and then she starts to tell me
that her mom heard a story about a woman
approaching people in our target parking
lot for help and there's another woman
that was inside my target um following
this her neighbor across the street has
two young kids three and five the same
woman on three different occasions went
up to this woman and said oh your
children are so good-looking they're so
cute they're so good-looking
and like kept like eyeing them
throughout the store so can't call
privacy like good-looking you could say
they're cute but when you say they're
good-looking I know and so I was like
this is happening like it's not just
that Target that's happening in my
managers area this is happening and in
my target like five minutes from my
house it's so scary well okay so that's
what slaps forcer be but what's bad
whatcha I'm kidding let's see do you
have a slap that will balance out the
depravity and depth of that chap's
no I mean I did watch cheer on Netflix
which is a docu-series on cheerleading
that was riveting yeah
yeah that's a good show great so if
you're worried about the horrors of sex
trafficking and kidnapping in your local
target watch cheer ow
like what Slavoj champion in your life I
also I'm only gonna go for one chaps all
I've a lot they all center around
coronavirus but I'm gonna serve with
slaps office to deal with coronavirus
not that coronaviruses slaps butt so I
know I hate on a lot of brands for
trying to be cool on social media but
I'm gonna be positive this week and
what's nice is there's something
negative in here I just had to sneak it
in dumb websites are creating dumb DIY
guides - hand sanitizer for fighting
coronavirus that don't actually work and
I guess some of them included putting
like Tito's vodka which is I think 40%
alcohol by volume in it and this is not
the recommended strength of alcohol
according to the CDC
this isn't weird should I saw on
Facebook this is the CDC website so
Tito's is going around replying to all
the people who post these links saying
that this isn't strong enough can we
actually have the tweet if we could show
that or at least someone Daum tweeted
about it
mmhmm yeah they're just going around
being like please don't do this
this isn't this doesn't work trust
science so cool thanks Tito's vodka and
then for what chaps is also related
people have been posting off stuff about
hand-washing and one poll of British
people and I think we have that link in
the description somewhere we're gonna
post it but British people in our
hand-washing habits in the bathroom 21%
of men quote-unquote not always wash
their hands after [ __ ] well out
after [ __ ] oh you gotta not always
for this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and I don't
want to avoid shaming women but even
though the men are substantially grosser
because 13% of women do the same thing
again substantially less these are the
real monsters in society I think we
spend a lot of time scapegoating like
bad mothers and just like lots of groups
that we shouldn't but really these are
the monsters that work among us what if
it's a clean wipe though
one of the ones where it's so good that
you wipe and there's nothing there I
call that you know it's like the perfect
game it's like the are you one of these
monsters I know one of these monsters
but I do think I do think like the same
way a golfer hits a hole-in-one and that
becomes a part of their narrative to do
a perfect [ __ ] and wipe and there's
nothing there it's really the body at
peak performance and do you think though
that like even without [ __ ] there's not
tons of bacteria on your butthole
this is this is true but you know in
general people I just wonder with
genital hygiene it's the most protected
part of the body you you wash it
thoroughly in the morning and if you're
an adult you should be scrubbing
everything you you put a clean pair of
underwear over it then a pair of pants
over that I just feel like all the
exposed parts of the body are
significantly more disgusting I've never
prayed but your your inner
disgustingness although like you know if
you have certain like feces borne
viruses or bacteria
you're gonna spread that to people I do
have questions about I think everyone
should wash their hands after they pee
because P is gross but like he doesn't
really spread diseases like [ __ ] does so
even though I'm disgusted by it I can at
least be slightly more sympathetic but
also just like wash your hands a ton
because there's a pandemic going on and
so any excuse you can to kill germs soap
and water you don't [ __ ] need pure
all the time stop hoarding it that's
what she had okay and wait in your slap
oh yeah your slap was the tweet sorry
they kind of blended into one another
there's a clear line of demarcation I'll
be quick with my my chaps because it's
similar its coronavirus we talked about
it on this podcast the the biggest thing
I've hated about coronavirus besides the
fact that it's truly a pandemic that's
hurting people and in hitting vulnerable
populations and it's very sad and scary
I think it's made all of us realize how
much we touch our faces and how hard it
is to not touch our faces and that's
been my struggle the past couple weeks
is to be conscious of that and to adjust
my habits and that's been rough and I'm
I'm very scared about what's to come in
the coming months not to put panic in
anyone's hearts but we'll see I saw a
post from a friend in Italy today where
they've been quarantined for a while and
he was urging all of us in this country
to just like not do stuff
not go to concerts or events or whatever
kind of stain and kick it so so that's
that's that's chapping what's slapping I
forgot about this fun thing you can do
in America and other places which is if
you have a long day you can go buy a
single beer from a store and ask for a
small paper bag and walk home or just
take a walk while drinking a beer
I recommend it does I think it slaps
cops will stop you
the cops will not stop you okay I mean
maybe not you and there's nowhere you
live in Los Angeles it's a spread out
city and you you can you can do
something like that in general too the
reason for the paper bags cops don't
want to like waste time with you on that
I think if you do live let's say in like
a nice suburb outside of Dallas you
shouldn't do this because there's not a
lot of pedestrian traffic and the cops
might be bored in New York City it will
not protect you you can't do in York man
Bloomberg really messed things up for
you all they used to be a fun place with
a lot of recklessness and now it's all
it also depends like who you are and
like if the cops want to harass you like
you know like in college I used to walk
around Chelsea you know smoke and
certain drugs they wouldn't bother me oh
don't look like me they might bother
he means meth I'll say this then if you
if you are in a position in your life
for your city or where you live to
safely do something like that
it is kind of enjoyable and feels
transgressive in a small way if you are
in a city where that's harder then I
would just say get a coffee tumbler and
either make a cocktail in it or if you
want to be really safe make a coffee
based cocktail I'd suggest yeah that's
like the cold brew over ice add a little
bit of Bailey's some Jameson shake that
up add a little bit of sweetener if you
need to but you shouldn't cause of the
Bailey's you're you have a cocktail you
have coffee and if anyone asks its gonna
look like coffee in that cup so that's
my modified version of my my slap and
activity for this week is that okay Alec
yeah I mean I've done stuff like that
okay there we go
well we have a hell of a show if I can
say so myself we're gonna talk about
buying houses with your friends it's
really exciting we're gonna have a
special guest on I'm gonna just I'm
gonna not say who it is until it happens
to talk to us about there
dating Diaries and what it's been like
to be on the market in this digital age
but to get started I wanted to talk a
little bit about the dating dystopia
that I experienced while binge watching
the Netflix show love is blind if either
of you watched any of the show just so I
have a context for who I'm talking to
yes obsessed okay you watch if you watch
the whole show sir bee yes okay great
this is exciting and just for anyone
who's listening who hasn't watched this
if you haven't I would probably say you
shouldn't but the premise of the show is
they took a bunch of people I think 15
men 15 women all all heterosexual
couples put them in this warehouse
environment with no windows and every
day they would meet in these pods for
conversations now that just the key is
there is a dividing wall between them so
the men and women were not able to see
each other so they had lengthy
conversations and without seeing each
other physically many of these couples
ended up getting engaged once they were
engaged they were allowed to leave the
pods meet each other they then went on a
little honeymooners trip to Mexico to
explore the relationship then they went
back to Atlanta where they lived in a
really kind of corporate looking
apartment complex together for a week or
two and then the final step of this was
they planned an actual wedding with
their real families and friends and no
one knew who was gonna say what until
they were at the altar so when it was
hosted by a Nick and Vanessa Lachey
Nick Lachey of 98 degrees Fame who
multiple times in the show said and I'm
obviously Nick Lachey as if anyone knows
who you are that wasn't born in the
eighties but um the the show frames
itself as a grand experiment and in the
early episodes especially and it does
kind of reek of the fact that when they
were making the show they didn't know
what it was going to be called yet
because they rarely say love is blind in
the show so it seems like a very
slapdash production but they keep saying
you know in this grand love experiment
we will find out is love truly blind so
it gives you this framing of being a
show that's offering some sort of
sociological or scientific experiment
into the nature of love and if love
truly is blind and what they're really
doing is the sort of mind-body
experiment if we can separate the mind
from the body and have two minds
that are wholly rational in the tantrum
physicality talking to each other can
can we really find love in this way now
I think that involves and I'm sure the
producers didn't finish their
undergraduate philosophy courses but I
think the premise of the show involves
in this reading of Descartes in which we
think that the body can be separated
from the mind of course Descartes even
reminds us the two things are
interrelated and speak to one another
the the body is just the dumb version of
the mind but one of the most interesting
thing that happens early on the show at
least something I found interesting
surbhi can speak to this later is that
the men most of whom and no offense to
to all my jimbros out there we're just
like very stereotypical like gym guys
they were all very jacked they all had
like a short cropped haircut they all
had stubble they all had jobs that were
like marketing or personal trainer or
something don't wait they did this whole
show and didn't even put any like ugly
people with hot voices mmm yes and this
is the thing I was going to get super
weenie to say this now of course part of
the grand experiment was they were all
relatively hot by conventional standards
the biggest misdirect was like one guy
was like kind of short anion yeah and
like once again shouts to my short kings
no disrespect but there was like a short
guy and then there was like some people
of color and they tried to like get a
lot out of that but there wasn't really
any big surprise to be had no matter
what you were going to end up meeting
someone who by conventional standards
was at least relevant not even
relatively pretty attractive so yeah one
of the weird things I noticed watching
this show was how emotional the men got
when they were detached from physicality
and by emotional I mean every man on
this show broke down in tears when
proposing to the woman of their choice
in a way that seemed very shocking
considering these were like jimbros now
the thing that happened though is of
course as soon as physicality was
brought back into it these men's
personalities changed completely they
became aggressive possessive jealous
insecure emotionally detached all these
sorts of things so if we're gonna say
the show says anything smart has any
interesting cultural commentary I think
it got at maybe like male fragility a
little bit and
what happens when a man has put in like
a quote-unquote safe space and is
detached from physicality overall though
I feel like the show is it made me feel
very gross like by the end of it
I felt bad I couldn't stop watching it
but I felt unclean it really feels like
their experiment I mean honestly the
Stanford Prison Experiment makes me feel
better than the experience that goes on
in this show and their version of
science truly feels like phrenology or
something like that the level at which
they're getting into the experiment now
I want to give a few quotes from some of
what's been written about this show
there was a guardian review that's a
pretty fantastic read that opens with on
in many ways this is a quote it is the
final blow to the final nail in the
coffin of civilization and possibly
humanity as we know it the description
of this show now the at the end of the
same article the author says anyway love
is blind is absurd revolting and deering
toxic and wholesome by terms and
addictive as hell throughout it's a very
fair review because it gets it the fact
that it in an intellectual level the
show is disgusting but you cannot stop
watching it which is why I'm telling you
right now if you don't have time don't
start the New Yorker I had an
interesting piece about it and the title
of The New Yorker piece was love is
blind is offensive to human dignity
which is into a success and this B says
that love is blind is morally offensive
to human dignity is key to its artistic
success one sees the clear potential to
build build it into a significant
franchise I'm imagining future seasons
and a black mirror crossover episode at
an expansion of the formula into a speed
dating service whereby single people
dating blind grope for meaning in the
darkness so I this show has inspired
some some takes that are basically
implying that it's a dystopian
experiment in dating in the veil of
trying to do something progressive and
scientific it ends up creating a sort of
hellscape and and I think the I'll stop
I'll say this and then we can talk about
it but I think the promise of this show
seems to be that like devoid of social
media and our shallow culture people can
find true love but it doesn't work if
the people in this experiment are
already so infected by our culture
to begin with it makes me think of the
idea not to get too political here but
the thought that there's kind of no
outside to capitals no outside to the
system of marketization that we
currently live in just in the same way
there's no outside to our dating culture
you can't take people whose entire
dating world and we'll get into this
later takes place on tinder and digital
apps and involves the complete
fetishization of appearance and
magically put them in a room and have
that go away
and I guess I won't spoil the show I
will say that that some people do
actually get married through the whole
process I'll say that that we had actual
marriages and at the end they have a
reunion special that tells us the show
was filmed a year ago and some of these
people are actually married Wow
yeah so I mean maybe surbhi are though
Alok of your jump into the bit please
talk I'm curious what's everything sir
yes no I agree with you I hated it but I
loved it
Friday off of work last week to watch ah
you started watching it on Thursday
night and then Friday morning I was like
my first call doesn't start till like
11:00 like I could I could do a show and
then I yeah we stayed up till 8 a.m. on
a work night in my house to finish
watching because we couldn't so I relate
to this yeah and so I couldn't stop
watching it and I also was interested in
the fact that the men were so vulnerable
and open even when talking about
something as simple as their favorite
book from childhood there was a man who
broke down and I was like what like how
did this happen um and then the other
thing that I thought was interesting was
they people kept saying things like like
when they went from the they went from
like the shared house to the vacation in
Mexico and then they went to living
together in the apartment the one thing
they kept saying was how was this going
to be we're gonna have our phones and
we're gonna have social media again how
is that going to affect us and that was
baffling to me that they were concerned
about their relationship in the face of
social media and nobody even knew the
two of them were together so it's not
like they were concerned about public
scrutiny they were just concerned
the fact that they had to talk to their
family and friends and they would have
access to Instagram again and one woman
god yeah one woman gets screamed at by
her partner cuz like she was
instagramming and not texting him back
and we see a fight about this that takes
place in the gym of course yeah and he's
like phone and she's like that's my job
it's to be on my phone like what are you
saying yeah so go ahead Ali no no sorry
yeah yeah so I thought that I was just
interesting that like that was the thing
that was the most concerning to them not
the fact that oh we had only met two
weeks before it was how are we going to
be in social media yeah someone hadn't
brought this up Michael maybe as you
maybe was Amanda one of our writers
Netflix is trying to essentially make
all these reality shows that are tapped
into like black near dystopia what's the
other one that we talked about the the
circle which is a Big Brother style
reality show I haven't watched it but it
seems like they're trying to do
something smart but it sounds very dumb
but like it would have been at least
maybe not interesting because I think we
would have all seen it coming but like
they could have asked hard questions
like what if like every single dude was
like just all of the objectives like not
objective sorry all this sort of like
stereotypical ideals of like beauty just
like the opposite of that
like you know scrawny short yeah
whatever you need to do and similarly
like with the women or like pair people
together specifically like if there is a
guy who's like I want to date tall
chicks like get him like a really short
girl and if it girls like I only date
short dudes like get them you know what
I'm saying essentially like [ __ ] with
them in that way but it didn't do any of
that to really expose how we're all not
we're all these people a lot of people
are shallow monsters is what I'm trying
to say maybe that's too predictable but
I don't know I'm skeptical of the whole
thing is I think we are yeah and I think
like Serbia's example about the couple
that that literally sheds tears and I
forget the exact book but just like
talking about they read the same kids
book and honestly like if you're of a
certain age there was five kids books we
all read the same ones but the depth of
the Congress
is shockingly shallow throughout and
once again maybe there was things the
producers left on the cutting room floor
but the deepest conversation we saw is a
couple that had a fight about politics
in which he said but are you ever gonna
change your mind on politics and she
says my beliefs are my beliefs they're
important to me and he said but they're
not flexible and she said no and then
they made out across a table in a
restaurant which would have deeply upset
me so so yeah I mean I think there's
there's an opposite version of this show
or maybe a modification I would like to
see that was called something like stat
sheet where people were matched up based
on like their actual beliefs and ideas
and adult books they've read or
something like that I think that'd be
interesting to match people up with
in-depth things but with people who
maybe they wouldn't traditionally be
attracted to but all these like none of
these people and I know and some of them
seemed like they were kind of genuine
but I don't want to be mean we all know
I'm getting that I think it was
interesting that even so there was this
one woman who was attracted to the short
guy just he wasn't short I'm just
calling him the short guy yeah um but
she was initially attracted to a
different guy and she would go on and on
about how he's the typical guy she would
go out with even though she had never
seen him so once she finally meets the
shorter guy and she sees the original
guy together
she continues to pursue the original guy
and I thought that it was interesting
that you're you're attracted to what
you're used to and what you know so even
though this guy might have been the
stronger pairing for her based off of
her values and what she wanted she she
couldn't accept it and she wouldn't
allow herself to fall in love with him
she still wanted the other guy yeah and
even one of the other couples I guess I
won't say names in case you no longer
but there's another couple that gets
together and they're both really sweet
but like they won't have sex or be
intimate with each other and as it
slowly reveals one of the partners and
that couple is like I love them just as
like a friend so you have these people
that are like going to their actual
wedding with their actual families there
who can't be intimate with each other
because they're truly not attracted to
each other
wait but they still get married I don't
want to reveal anything all say as some
couples get married we do get to see in
the show and this isn't spoiling
anything couples at the altar with their
families there who when asked do you
take this person they say no I'm good
and it gets a little awkward but that's
one of the things I think is the most
reckless not to be all like that I'm
someone that cares too much about the
sanctity of marriage like whatever dude
you but it's kind of [ __ ] up to be in
this scenario we have like your aging
parents there and childhood friends and
family members for this thing that it
does make a mockery of the institution
of marriage and the idea of lifelong
monogamy so it's it's not the best in
that sense I mean setting to because
they brought the families together like
in a lot some of these situations the
families met each other so it's like
you're just gonna say no at the altar
after you've already got into another
family I find that very upsetting
well we should we should move on because
we're staying in a similar realm but I
will ask this of everyone here and this
is the question that Nick and Vanessa
Lachey asked all of the participants in
the show at the reunion special start
with you Alec is love blind pass sir be
his love blind so I'm not I'm I've never
really gone out with a guy according to
his looks so for me I'm not interested
in that's why I mean I I there attract
people are attractive to me if they're
like kind and funny and things like that
and then I find them physically
attractive so to me love is blind
well I really love that response and I
do think it was the correct one I'm not
gonna say anyone had an incorrect answer
but I'm gonna say I'm gonna say halfway
I think that if you're someone who
values the the intellect and kindness
and some of the things that servitors
talked about I do think love can be
blind I do think if you're an adult that
works in marketing and your favorite
book is still a children's book and you
spend most of your time at the gym
anyways it might be the case that love
isn't blind and you just want a hot bod
to kick it with and I don't judge that I
like it when like hot people that like
working out and chilling it together why
not why not but I don't think love is
now we have a guest here today for our
next segment you might have heard of him
you probably have we have Jared here
with us today hey what's up guys yeah
good to be back
yeah the sort of Don Corleone II of the
wisecrack crime family and he's here to
talk to us about his recent experiences
in dating well the interesting thing is
that two of the people here have been in
relationship so long that they've never
had to experience online dating and you
know that would be Michael and Alec and
so I decided that now that I'm back on
the online dating game I would subject
myself to their questions and tell you a
little bit about the misery that is
online dating Wow yeah and you know
Jared complains to me about his life
often not just everything it's part of
Alec's job in his job description it
says here Jared commiserate yeah and I
always love when Jared complains in very
philosophical ways about things that are
not necessarily philosophical so one I
think the two things I want to talk to
Jared about are finding or like
determining having an existential crisis
when making your online dating profile
as Jared is currently having and the
second one is Jared was on a date that
did not go well but somehow it spiraled
into a conversation about [ __ ] jobs
and how people can plate their careers
with their identity yeah so we'll go one
at a time yeah I want to start with
Jared what are some of the stress what
are some of the struggles and sort of
deep existential questions well first of
all what is building a profile even like
for you building an online profile is
like a dating profile is akin to staring
straight into the abyss of your own
identity because because of course you
have to ask yourself who am i what am I
good at what do I like all these
questions that the dating app assumes
are easy to answer questions and even
you know maybe normal people would say
those are easy to answer questions but
I've always
you know someone like me I've always had
a bit of an identity crisis where I'm
pulled between these two very different
identities there's like very much like a
type-a part of me and then there's very
much a Type B kind of like lazy media
obsessed kind of I'm down to just watch
movies all weekend kind of guy and so
the question is always well how do what
do I say do I say that I'm both of these
things do I say that I'm one of these
things and it's actually quite sad when
you test these things because previously
I had done the douchey thing and
optimized my profile to present myself
how you would think someone would want
to see you so you know I would say like
oh I started this business I'm really
driven blah blah blah and then you know
you emphasize the entrepreneur goddammit
uber got there and then you emphasize
the things that you do maybe like once
every two months like hiking traveling
all the stuff that you think people want
to hear and unfortunately in my
experience those are the things that get
the responses and so I have this old
dating profile that I reactivated and it
had my old info on there and that one
seems to be doing well but then since
then there since I've been in you know I
was in a relationship for like almost
three years and then since that ended
there been a lot of new dating apps that
have come up so I just joined some of
those and I started to create a new
profile and I asked myself you know I
learned a lot in this last relationship
and I'm going to present myself in a way
that I think is more accurate or I've
learned more about myself I've learned
more about what it's like to be in a
relationship and so I definitely
emphasized this type B element of me the
kind of person who's like if you want to
go see Lohengrin at the LA opera while
really high we're gonna get along and
that person is getting no love on how
many individual apps that you are
currently presenting yourself on I'm
only on three but I've downloaded like
six and seriously the the challenge of
creating a profile is so painful that
I've downloaded the apps but stopped
short of creating the profile because of
course then there's choosing the
pictures
being completely blind to which pictures
look good or look accurate or how long
is too long before you need to take a
new picture is a two year old picture
too old yes it is what do you think is
the right eye I think I think you should
have your main pictures to be within the
past six months and I think that a
majority of the future should be in the
past twelve to eighteen I feel like a
lot of people though stay pretty static
for like I look I think I look the same
as I do two years ago but I think we all
think that we all think yeah I really
sorry Michael and you're this element of
the algorithm that kind of place it some
of these apps will place you in this
algorithmic thing where you now
understand your level of attractiveness
from this seemingly objective standpoint
and that can be horrifying that's
staring straight into the abyss because
maybe it's an algorithm maybe it's math
doing something magical - oh I've heard
about this algorithm and I think it's
very similar in academia maybe Burns
knows a little bit more about this
there's an impact score where like if
you're cited a lot of times it means
you're important but if the people
citing you are cited a bunch of times
that means you're even more important
right like if the hot-shit philosopher
cites you in a paper therefore you're
also hot [ __ ] and that's kind of what
Google rankings were based off of
originally but I think it happens where
if someone's like likes your profile or
swipes right or whatever and they also
have a high swipe right the algorithms
like oh dear top [ __ ] you know we're
gonna we're gonna show him - although
like hot people which is horrifying it's
just another way of measuring your
self-worth in a way that is potentially
horrifying mm-hmm Wow so like what are
the number averages for this and by that
I mean for how many people you contact
how many contact back and then from how
many you are in contact with does it
lead to an actual date roughly speaking
well back then so now every dating app
is basically tinder back in the day you
would be able to message somebody
blindly whether or not they're
interested in you but these days it's
all about swiping there are subtle
variations and various apps but it's all
about swiping if you get connected then
you you know you get to message that
person in terms of numbers I would say
even if you get connected it's like a
50% chance that they'll respond and
stuff like that and so you ask yourself
then it's like okay well why did this
person swipe right in the first place is
it because maybe my first picture looked
good but my rest of my pictures didn't
look good or maybe they didn't read my
profile and once they read it they were
uninterested it's just really kind of
soul soul soul crushing in a lot of ways
I swiped right on you real that's real
we swiped right as told the other that's
so good years ago yeah I sent him a few
flirty messages they went unanswered
dance because I someone knew on the
phone I had her number so I figured that
you know I wanted to text you back
without giving away any data survey all
the listeners know they are not
currently in the same room right now so
the tension isn't palatable no it's um
so that's good for me wait so I have a
question do you think and this is more
of a theoretical thing I'm kind of
obsessed with this and I wish I once
said to my partner I wish I could online
date as an experiment cuz I've never
really gotten to like live in though
I've said that to my partner
yeah on the couch for a weekend or my
theory would be that I feel like most
people probably put their best picture
is their main picture my theory would be
I'm going my second or third best
picture for my main picture then when
you like swipe me and you go to my
profile the next picture you see is
gonna be my best one so you're you're
liking me on what's like solid that's a
Power Move yeah cuz then when you get
into it you're not like oh he does
really look like that you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah and I what that would probably
decrease your first level numbers of
like initial swipes right but would you
rather get the one picture swipes or
less of those but then when people get
involved they see more I'm speculating
so I've never been on these apps that
would be my theory so some of these apps
have almost like freemium mobile games
they have incentives to keep logging in
every day they even have you know
economy like so for example the app that
surbhi and I swiped each other on was
coffee meets bagel where they actually
have coffee beans which are things that
you can accumulate and spend to open up
messages with certain people or whatever
but because it keeps on getting you back
to login and then every time you log in
and you don't see that number of
notifications that you would want to see
you're always saying oh should I be
optimizing it a little more should I be
changing that photo so I have similarly
come up with these game plans of saying
yeah I'm gonna do one picture that's
maybe a little less flattering just so
that I attract the most honest people
but you know after a couple days where
that stops working or doesn't work at
all you start saying to yourself [ __ ]
maybe I'm just completely wrong and so
you just because you're logging in every
day and expecting something every day
you end up kind of just driving yourself
crazy thinking what do i optimize this
and at what point is optimizing creating
this other digital self I mean ever
since I don't know maybe you guys had
the same experience but ever since
talking on the internet was a thing with
like AOL Instant Messenger just showed
my age there was always this division
between my real life self and how I can
speak to somebody in the digital world
and I feel like that's put on steroids
in the dating game in a way that you
know maybe you're better at telling
jokes when you're on AOL Instant
Messenger or through text or whatever
but
the way that you have to present
yourself holistically as this is what I
look like physically these are why I'm
an attractive person this is why I am
worthwhile as a human being is just all
the more frustrating and yeah just
potentially really soul-crushing I also
imagine there's a double-edged sword in
that not that you'd ever describe
yourself this way but you could put your
bio like I'm a media executive or
something and in LA I'm sure lots of
people would really like that but the
people who swiped on you for that reason
would probably be awful whereas like if
you put I'm a writer well I think you
also identifies that those people might
be a little bit cooler yeah it's tough
sir be go ahead you need to put your
best picture as your first picture
because I just said love is blind but
when I was using those apps
I found myself becoming more shallow and
when you're just faced with an endless
number of men it's like no no no no so
your first picture has to be really nice
your profile can't say things like
especially here in LA it can't say
things like I'm a writer I'm a media
executive everybody's a writer
everybody's a media executive
everybody's a model yeah it doesn't mean
it doesn't it doesn't mean anything it's
not interesting you're better off saying
things like I like these kinds of movies
or this is my favorite band or on the
weekends I enjoy walking my dog like
things like that that give me a glimpse
into what you like to do
Jared can we do a social experiment and
just do a Nicholas Cage themed profile
and just just just do it for a week or
two and then see maybe you'll get a cool
date with someone who's really into
watching vampires kiss and Mandy young
no work knowing it's a horrible idea
it's a great idea someone who's gonna
murder someone
oh it says coffee shop here's the
address and they look it up on Google
Maps and it just shows like a warehouse
and you're no no it's like new we talked
about earlier in that target no just a
service point even I mean from a male
perspective to maybe even especially it
really does train you to be shallow
because there are so many people that
it's presenting you with at all times
who live and in LA maybe this isn't
something that's different but since la
is so big you know you'll be getting
people from Long Beach and it's like 30
miles away you know I'm not gonna drive
the Long Beach so you're getting so mint
yet basically you're getting so many
people that it just trains you to just
say alright well if I'm not physically
attracted to this person then it's
probably not gonna go too much farther I
mean the problem is is that a telephone
is very much at least in the way that's
being used here a visual medium and so
the visual is always going to be the
most important part and you know so I
think that your strategy of putting your
best picture third or fourth you would
probably change that after being like
disappointed after a while and feeling
and just watching yourself fall and that
algorithm of attractiveness and then
that's just it's just a kind of a gross
thing to even think about well there's
the question for Serbian and Jared is
this all there is now if you are if you
are dating in this world is do people
even consider the opportunity of
organically meeting someone out and
about or is this it I'll be honest no
well this was a couple years ago but I
have asked girls out on the street like
not just you know like after a
conversation but you know usually
because I'm with my I have my dog they
had a dog usually that starts up a
conversation I'll usually wait till the
third or fourth time that I run into
them and they don't like it I remember
they just don't like me I mean that's
also a possibility but I don't know yeah
I've had people tell me that asking and
I've had people say like oh my god you
have someone out on the street what are
you a psycho yeah and I always thought
that that was kind of a ballsy romantic
move but I don't know really it's maybe
a better question for servi so I I'm
torn part of me likes that idea I would
like I prefer to meet somebody
organically but when I have been so I
don't get asked out ever but the one
time I did get asked out like just I
think I was shopping at Trader Joe's it
it made me nervous not because I thought
that the guy was like a killer or
anything but just
I started to think like I don't know
anything about him I don't know who he
is what his name is or anything like I
can't go out with him like what if he
kills me or kidnaps me or something and
so I said no but had we met like through
a friend or at work or through something
else I would have said yes so I didn't
want to like blow your spot up here but
surbhi told us this before that man was
Chris Evans and she could have been with
him and she chose not to sorry to blow
up your spot but no way so what did he
what did he say and we were talking
about um so I was I was getting bread
gluten-free but bread and so he he asked
me a question about it and so we started
talking and then obviously I opened up
with all my food allergies which is
really attractive and then he just sort
of said something like oh well would you
like to go out to there's he said
there's an allergen free bakery that he
knows us and if I wanted to go and like
get something with him and I was like oh
that's so nice
but I was like oh no I can't do that
because I don't know you and I'm afraid
and yeah you know I got scared I I did I
used to work with somebody they like
kept a spreadsheet of like I think they
had something like a thousand messages
like 50 replies only like five dates
they'd been married at this point for I
think over five years maybe ten had a
child together he met her in line to get
a bagel like just at the coffee that the
the bagel I just been oh hey and start
chatting and is now happily married to
that person I mean yeah I'm saying a
coffee shop so is that true yeah I'm
just sitting next to each other in a
coffee shop I ended up casually doing
what year this would have been
weights over 20 20 2013 so 2013 that's
when the dating was are not being yeah
and stream like I I had downloaded
tinder because someone told me about it
right before I met my fiancee and I had
I had an account on him
OkCupid I think at one point it was not
like you have to write like an essay
about yourself but yeah cuz I remember
in 2010-2011 there was still a big
stigma against them
and yeah I even once tried the
Craigslist personal section just because
I was like [ __ ] you know what I would
ever see what happens that did not go
well and we're happy that's the story
for another time yeah before before we
move on which sadly we have Jude is Alec
sir be any any last probing questions
for Jared and while he's on this
romantic digital journey I think we have
to ask you about your bad date for
another time which I think I think
people will want because we are running
out of time but I do want to have Jared
on here regularly and I mean surpise on
here anyway but I'm fascinated by this
world and all the existential questions
that come out maybe it just as a wheel I
got a question for sir be what you are
you just hoping to meet some guy in real
life now what are you Andy and Ruth all
I got out of so I I'm very very much
still in love with that guy so I don't
think I'm dating anytime soon but when I
if I do feel ready today I'd rule I
would hope to meet somebody that like
somebody can introduce me to you just
because I apparently just clam up and
get really nervous when somebody
approaches me in public because I get
scared I will say for any women that are
listening Jared is a catch absolutely
date him he's so hot in person really
smart really funny very kind and I would
love and help you yeah profile he's
taller than you'd think
and I feel like women do stereotypically
like tall men and I'm constantly shocked
day in day out that jared is always
taller than I think youth it's like
you're growing every day I thought he
was short before I met him in person and
then I show up to LA and he's [ __ ]
almost as tall as me I'm like what the
full a like Alec is a giant I'll say
this boy I know Alec is talking me yeah
I'm six four four and I'm dating someone
who's five feet five foot one Wow like a
shack and cookie Scituate now what was
her name I think shacks first wife her
name was cookie or something she was
five one but that's an as my topic for
next time
well we do have to move on from this
because we got a live show ahead of us
but Jared thank you for sharing your
soul in this oh yeah the vulnerability
here is attractive and impressive oh
thank you I hope that it
insightful and not just sad yes and I'm
gonna talk about this before we end to
but just right now while it's in
everyone's mind if you want to share
your thoughts opinions and stories from
these struggles of online dating you can
also always hit us up culture at
wisecrack oh and we'll give you the
number later but right now what we have
to do is get into our final topic of the
day everything that has to do with
intimacy at some level so now we're
gonna get into a platonic cohabitation
surbhi tell us about home buying with
friends yes okay so there was a recent
article in the Atlantic about two
couples that recently purchased a home
together their philosophy is that life
is better living in a community of runs
and so they share everything from the
mortgage to their cell phone plan
grocery bills and dinner I think every
night and I started to think about this
idea of living with friends and buying
property together and this living
arrangement wouldn't work for me mostly
just because I'm very intensely private
but also I I'm not I have a lot of
acquaintances and like a handful of
really close friends and even though
those friendships are quite intimate and
close they're not at that level where I
would feel comfortable wanting to live
with them and buying buy a home with
them and I also don't want to feel like
I'm back in college living with the
roommates and then I came to the part of
the article in which one of the men says
something like he was going through a
career in a financial crisis and it was
nice to have other people other than his
wife to depend on and to listen to his
problems and so I started to think about
this more broadly and I do think that
there is something nice about wanting to
build a community at home and to have a
larger support network and people to
rely on in order to combat isolation or
to feel more engaged with others so
while this living arrangement wouldn't
work for me I can see the benefits and I
want to have a two-part discussion about
this I know we're running out of time
but just very quickly I want to know
would you be interested in buying a home
and living with your friends I
objectively would yes I don't think my
partner would that I would you were to
live with friends oh I would I've
actually talked about it with some
friends before and had like loose vague
dreamy plans about it one involved so a
thing you get a lot in LA our houses
that have like these like carriage
houses or guest houses in the back so
there's like two houses technically on
one property and at one point me my
partner we're talking to my best friend
about like a world or maybe we all went
in on it together
I I loved the idea personally how what
do you think I don't know if I'd buy a
home with somebody else because that
seems like a we like it seems like it go
wrong so many ways but IM pro living
with roommates I mean I don't right now
I live with my partner I don't think I
could get back in the habit of living
with people mostly for reasons of like
I've had disgusting roommates I'm kind
of disgusting
me and my partner like we've met a good
balance like I'm fine for her to know my
shame of how disgusting I am and for her
to give me [ __ ] about it and vice versa
I don't want to bring other people in
there but you know before I was living
for years and years at one place with
like three other roommates you know I
lived in dorms and like a suite style
and I like those times are great like I
just living with my friends obviously
there's issues about when your roommate
takes the mop and decides to clean the
toilet with it because that's the thing
normal people do but I do find like I
think this happens to for all you
slightly younger listeners in a couple
years all your friends are gonna like
shack up with her boyfriend or
girlfriend and you're gonna see them
less and you're like oh they live far
away it's hard to see each other they're
doing all this stuff and I think living
with other people can just solve a lot
of those problems and like they'll I
think like people often do need a sense
of community or support network or all
those things I think my ideal situation
is all my friends just move to my
neighborhood which I'm constantly trying
to convince them to so Michael sir be
moved to Brooklyn it's great
neighborhood I would that's I think
wisecrack should do a move to another
city why why are we in LA let's go well
that's why I got to find Jared a
girlfriend
Brooklyn and then he will uproot the
whole company I've been trying to get
into I feel like there's various reasons
he would he would do better finding a
girlfriend in New York but I won't get
into that right now
well but I do think as well maybe some
surpise gonna get into I do think this
is a kind of uniquely American
phenomenon the view like living in such
an isolated context I know for example
like the I lived in the UK for a while
and there it's pretty normal for people
that aren't married well into their 30s
or 40s to like still live together and
not a lot of people live alone just
because and I even knew couples there
that shared places and I know in a lot
of Europe and in Latin America it's
pretty normal to like live at home with
your family until you are married so it
is a kind of thing we we do to ourselves
uniquely in terms of social isolation in
this way yeah it is and that was
something that I thought was interesting
was like the community aspect so it's
very common in Asian cultures for you to
live at home or to live in
multi-generational households so that
wasn't foreign to me but what I thought
was interesting was the idea of living
with friends like see that's the thing I
couldn't I couldn't get around to like I
could see living with family and living
with like I'd way rather of a friends
yeah I couldn't and even though like I
like my mom and stuff so I would like to
live with her but the idea of living
with like my grandparents I couldn't do
it are living with really just like a
handful of family members I could live
with but I think it's the fact it's like
buying property together I could do I
think that's that's what would make me
hesitate and I could see so many
problems with that like what happens if
you get in a fight or what happens if
one of the couples breaks up or
something like what is the division of
assets look like like things like that I
wouldn't like to do is buying property
and tying yourself financially to
somebody else yeah yeah I'm like weird
with money and by that I mean bad with
money so that that wouldn't be a thing I
would think about and I would be the one
that would go into it with some logic of
like okay so we'll pay the mortgage
proportionally based on income everyone
currently has so we're technically
participating the same amount and blah
blah blah but like I know that wouldn't
work and it would get messy
but I don't know I think if people
weren't as weird about money it'd be
easier and then you just have to sign a
contract that says you can't break up
with that person or if you break up with
them you immediately have to have
another partner that moves in and takes
their slot yeah
it's reasonable mean I I think we will
see a lot more of this though I mean
it's already
you mentioned the UK New York similarly
like I know a lot of people in their 30s
40s I don't know how this person maybe
50 have a roommates with or without
partners and just because New York is so
expensive
maybe the UK is also similar to that and
I think as there's like as people keep
moving into cities and there's like less
and less apartments and they get more
expensive you're gonna see it but I
think I mean I always complain that we
live in tiny closets for too much money
but that is one upside as well have
friends well there's them a new startup
you company that's sort of like we work
for apartments I think it's called tree
house oh that's a dystopian nightmare
yeah it's hell and they they're opening
one or just open one in LA and for
anyone hasn't heard of this it's
basically like a glorified college dorm
for Millennials that work in tech where
you have like a literal tiny room that
yours shared living space kitchen
bathroom stuff like that they play in
communal activities and the rent is a
lot it's like not cheap I looked into it
out of curiosity and it's still very
expensive but it really is like living
in a tech dystopian wework dorm
environment and I wonder if things like
that aren't going to continue to rise in
popularity both as a way to sort of
vampiric ly suck as much money as
possible out of this weird tech culture
we live in and also to respond to the
housing crisis yeah and those are I
think extra shitty because this might
sound cool but like they provide all the
cleaning for you so there can never be
fights about it but as someone who have
done a dorm for a long time was an RA
and had to deal with like shitty
roommate disputes people who do that are
like unable unable and unwilling to like
grow up in [ __ ] moth before and it's
just sort of enabling these horrible
like tech bros or like whatever like I
just don't ever have to learn to do my
own laundry
that's bad I do know of a woman who
lives in like a group home scenario in
the Bay Area so they all live in like
apartments and then they also have a
kitchen and a communal like living space
downstairs and she says it's great
because she's like rather than live at
home I get to live in this like larger
community with people and I can have my
own space but then I can also go
downstairs and eat dinner with a bunch
of people if I want to I'd say I think
that sounds nice I thought I once again
I like being around people but I do I
still think back to Alex point about
living in the same neighborhood I mean
that would be my dream that all my best
friends live within walking distance of
each other in the same neighborhood and
we can literally just meet up at our
like local bar or coffee shop I guess
like as a mix between friends and How I
Met Your Mother
or Seinfeld and just have that like
communal place I think that would be
really nice to live in such a way that I
could have my own space but also know
that I could have proximity to friends
that I care about and that's bracketing
the money thing of course yeah well
further thoughts on this er beer okay
great um so let's well before you wrap
up let's do some emails and as a
reminder we love to hear from you if you
think we just say that for shits and
giggles we don't it's awesome and
especially any of these topics today if
if you've been on a reality dating show
if you're currently on dating apps and
if you're think about buying home with
friends we'd love to hear what you think
about this or just anything else you
think applies to the general realm of
things we talked about
so please do hit us up at culture binge
at wisecrack Oh remember know em culture
banjo wisecrack oh oh or call us at 1 2
1 3 5 3 4 8 8 0 7 that is 1 2 1 3 5 3 4
8 8 0 7 leave us a voicemail we'd love
to hear from you and hear your voice
it's really fun so do that in the
meantime
alik what have we heard from our
delicious and wonderful fans this week
well the first one is from Jay I guess
last episode you were talking about
purposely getting hit by a car financial
yeah yeah good thing I'd want to do
somebody yes yeah so here's Jay like
everyone else I'm a huge fan
of all your work thanks Jay it's helping
me keep my sanity through law school
which is a huge deal oh yeah awesome oh
yeah speaking of that that's actually
why Jay is writing today in the last
episode Michael mentioned that he had
yeah he had given not entirely goofy
thought to maybe getting hit by a car on
purpose so that he could win a lot of
money in a lawsuit and be more
financially stable since I care about
you guys and we like culture bench to
continue I just wanted to let Michael
know that this would almost certainly
not work out well obviously I'm a law
student so this is not legal advice
California follows what's called the
comparative negligence theory put way
too simply this basically means that in
accident situations the party pay the
respective responsibility for that
accident
so in Michaels hypothetical let's assume
that a court found that Michael was 50%
responsible for the accident while the
driver was 50% responsible to be asked
that seems optimistic for Michael let's
further assume Michael suffers $100,000
in total damages medical expenses time
off and wisecrack etcetera under
California law the driver would only Oh
Michael $50,000 half of Michael's
damages because the driver was only half
to blame for the accident in this case
Michael would have lost $100,000 but
only recouped 50,000 so don't do that
okay
on to plan B and thank you so much
that's awesome these are the emails we
love tell us why we're stupid with the
knowledge that you have that we don't
that's incredible thank you so much it's
great Jay thanks yeah thank you and good
luck with the rest of Law School I hear
that's tough but that's awesome and
you're gonna crush it and let us know
how it goes the next one is an email
from Ariel who we were talking last week
about organ donation Ariel disagrees of
pain is that the right name I think it
is sorry if I miss wrote your name so
this from Ariel I won't chime in on the
organ donation issue which is an
extension of the freedom of self and
body debate the argument against what
organ donation for money selling organs
let's call it by its name is that for
poor people this may not be a choice at
all that they will be forced to sell a
kidney to make ends meet sure when you
don't have money or about to get your
house repossessed and a little bit under
crushing debt it may seem like you don't
have a choice but to sell a kidney but
actually you do have a choice because
nobody's forcing you to sell your kidney
you have something as bare
evaluable that can actually solve many
of your problems opposing opposition of
selling organs is actually the thing
that nice people are this freedom when
you can't sell your kidney then you
really have no choice but to be crushed
by said debt say you have a serious
medical condition that you can't afford
to treat sure something kidney would add
another medical condition but otherwise
you may just die of your first untreated
one another perspective that has ignored
this are the people who are sick who
need the kidneys opposing opposition to
organ transplants for money to protect a
person from health issues do is another
person death from similar issues I think
well you go I respectfully disagree I
mean there is a part of this that I
understand there's obviously the people
who need the kidneys it stimulates all
that but go ahead I think you were gonna
say something Michael no III just also
uh I genuinely appreciate the thought of
the response I do respectfully disagree
because I think there's still I think
there still are levels of societal
control or pressure that could go into
that I think we just can't underestimate
what someone could be well not like
forced to do with a gun to their head
but forced to do due to financial
constraints in terms of this sort of
thing and I think that it's if anything
this email shows that it is a really
complicated issue and we can't solve it
in one podcast we'll have to solve it in
another episode but I respectfully
disagree but appreciate the thought yeah
and I think and this isn't 2-way one
over the other but I think it starts a
narrow view of freedom which is again
what I was saying before of am i free
without obstacles versus the freedom
from you know extraneous forces all that
good stuff and I'm saying one is worse
than the other like I think that's a
really intense problem right like I
think there is the unfreedom of being
coerced into doing something and then
the unfreedom of being told you can't do
something I also say like when it comes
to certain specific instances of
people's houses being repossessed and
all that stuff I would try to fix that
stuff on its own like there are large
overarching problems and I don't think
it's fair to take the most dystopian
part of our society and like be like
well this awful solution will fix it
any part of that but here's another
email from Ross same topic I'm sorry I
see I do appreciate the email I did
agree with many points and I don't think
that paying for organ donation is
something that should be like completely
off the table I think maybe we should
try to explore if there are ways to do
it but also protect people who are in
vulnerable situations cool so the next
email same topic is from Ross hey
wisecrack crew listening to the news
culture binge we're paying people donate
organs was topic and this had me worried
on one big part I said this is the guy
signed up for organ donation that paying
people for donating their organs is a
very dangerous road the big problem I
see is almost all the people who didn't
donate their organs for monetary
exchange whether it's cash tax credits
or debt payments will be poor people and
those of the lower class we're an
injection of 50k is life-changing I
agree with Alec that there is a
potential for a class of people to exist
where organ donations is all they are
good for to Uppercross people I do think
offering others incentives such as the
vacation idea is not bad as a kind of
reward but the idea is to raise
awareness to get people signed up as
organ organ donators just my thoughts on
something I could easily see going wrong
and it being very hard to see going
right especially in America thanks the
cold Canadian Ross is this the same Ross
who gave us slurring advice I hope so I
like him hopefully another good take
another could take on that and I once
again I don't want to say I agree with
Ross because then he's mostly agreeing
with Alec and I would be acknowledging
that I think Alec says smart things so
I'm gonna be neutralness I think the
part of the email that made me pause and
my like mission to pay for organ
donations is where he said something
like people might view this class as
good for only organ donations and that
like I could see that happening where
like people could feel like oh like
you're just in you're just an organ
donor like what do you know like why
don't you go give me your kidney and
stuff
I mean a similar thing has happened in
that for a long time and my specific
contacts doing the research I've been
doing is in vaccine but I think happened
with a lot of pharmaceuticals straight
of testing them on orphans and they're
like yeah it's good for the orphans
health maybe some of them like the fact
it might have been you know these are
safety trials or efficacy trials and
kids died
not a lot of kids but too many kids and
they would just go to like the arch diet
or whatever in charge of these Catholic
orphanages and so it's not great not
good let's not do that anymore we don't
do that anymore I don't think
hopefully not we got any more emails or
is that it for today's back that's it
okay well that is it for us thank you so
much for sticking around we love having
you here like you said before please
call please email Alec if people need
more of you in their lives where can
they find you I don't know why they
would but at wisecrack Alec on Twitter I
tweet sometimes yeah sir be people if
they want to find you not looking for
gluten-free bread at Trader Joe's where
are you sir you ever tell 22 on Twitter
Oh follow her if you want to find me I'm
at Michael Oh burns on Twitter and I
think Michael Oh burns on Instagram as
well thank you for sticking around we'll
be back in two weeks and as always if
you like this you will like our other
podcast or other shows we have some new
stuff pop in these days so please
subscribe to the podcast subscribe to
our YouTube channel just become obsessed
with everything we do and we'll be
obsessed with you back in return for
Alec and surbhi I'm Michael this has
been culture binge and we'll see you
next time bye
[Music]